bientôt monde c'est ce midi en compagnie
de lucas et pour faire l'épisode 2 de
sliders alors on a fait le premier en
live si vous souvenez donc c'était la
map the eight days qui menaceront pas vu
d'ailleurs bon bref dans tous les cas on
est à la deuxième map qui s'appelle into
the abyss et j'ai avec moi une grosse ta
tête
ah oui alors je vais commencer à jouer
si je me fais but et c'est à vous de
jouer on va faire ça ok on est chaud ok
d'accord donc la vidéo sera encore sous
le ventre de zapping c'est bien plus
drôle
d'accord nous commencerons danse avec
modèle d'accord ok donc c'est parti
alors ou devons-nous aller je n'en ai
absolument aucune idée en fait dans
l'épisode d'avant slender c
amine ben aleya tomek d'accord qui s'est
renversé et donc là il se réveille à
l'aube le matin je pense ou alors tard
le soir le lendemain ouais une autour de
lignes rouges oui les cas qu'est-ce
qu'on a juste eu la mauvaise idée que
décrit tout le décor puisque tu vas tu
vas leur touche on a une c'est l'automne
tulsa unsa d'une ça donne ça tue sa
gauche alors la petite musique qui se
met en route je suppose qu'on va se
faire attaquer là dedans est-ce qu'il
faut trouver des pages d'ancenis votre
avis mongai à vinh et tu les as
president et coo mais y avait mes bandes
de sapri s'y attend maintenant parce
qu'il y avait un scrapbook voilà cinq
ans colling la salle probable est sûre
nous sommes battus jusqu'au sang gamme
oui nous avons bilingue
voilà un bilingue un bilingue français
c'est parler français et france soir tu
as tort désormais autant vous dire que
j'aime pas trop ambiant lucas c'est quoi
ça son du tout bien au loyer le must be
you found the man vers image ainsi life
as soon as possible
ok donc en gros tous les employés ont
été vidés du truc donc en gros d'avoir
un truc bizarre l'amiante
je suis pas ce cas dans la mine ça a
l'air plutôt stressant des flèches wata
c'est quoi ça le café voire par contre
les lumières autant dire que ces
lumières ne faudrait pas non on peut
prendre l'ascenseur temps des foules à
temps il y avait une petite indication
sur le mur je sais pas mais ça me fasse
happy and power est donc déjà ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir convaincre
[ __ ] sam j'aimerais bien trouver
comment sortir d'ici d'accord mais c'est
une blague
au pire ça non on peut ouvrir butin mais
il ya forcément un truc à faire bon les
gars faut forcément d'accord ok en fait
on avait trouvé voilà donc en fait faut
juste un mec serveurs agri
on va où tout droit ou à gauche me dit
tout droit il m'a dit ok bon ben voilà
on est des fous mais il faut faut
trouver des générateurs en fait faut
activer des biens de gueule c'est ce que
je fais ce que je fais c'est parce que
nous attaquer mais ça va je te ville
morte entre temps il y avait un moteur
me semble on a déjà activé le gars
fallait aller tout droit
parenthèse fermée alors à tomber ce
qu'il y aurait pas tu as entendu
ouais je sais quoi dans wow oh oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi
c'est quoi une pure bombe et non d'un
placard en position foetale au rouge de
merde
ça se paye il est où ce taux calculé que
je le rallume pas c'est tour des rallyes
suite l'épreuve a carrément [ __ ] mais
c'était quoi
oh
c'était quoi les gars ça mais c'est plus
länder qui nous attaque mon gars c'est
ça m c'est la copine newsletter en est
qu au temps de dire que ça fait bientôt
l'heure mon gars c'est mon mal payés des
chaînes voilà un mec d'emballage peu
plus mais franchement c'est trop
stressant surtout non vraiment là j'ai
des boutons qui pousse quoi en direct
live on les voit apparaître sur mon
visage suivre ça les mecs mais c'était
quoi on la 12e' en même temps c'est
schmitz au mec la tête de l'eau en
attendant le cas luca luca
au sud les oules faudrait à lembeye un
générateur envoie en faites vous un
certain nombre de fois je pense que tu
mords promec
il ya en fait il vient de prendre pour y
voir un bijou à chapeau qu'est ce qu'il
veut et le matin moi je pensais que
c'était du one shot genre d'arrêt me
bouffe comme des membres
j'ai l'impression qu'on affaiblit quand
même bah oui nous affaiblit arrête
[ __ ] tu bois tu maintenant wang va
alors qu'une fois t'es mort ok je vais
réussir à allumer générateur et on sera
deux fois aux mecs recrutant j'ai cru
monde comme jamais sur quoi là
2 sur 6 en fait celui d'avant il a fait
montre lors que le niveau d'avant crise
en poids - amr mais qui dès à lui
comme ignoble je vais parler ça tu le
sors tu sens tu ça a travaillé au mec tu
fais la suisse je suis le suivait le
rôle d'un chasseur l'a plus
joffrin de commande là bas là bas à
droite y avait un générateur est juste
là c'est juste la regarde est ce parce
que j'ai trouvé la salle du début
comment je n'aime pas le petit bonhomme
qui courent une fille là bas l'abba waro
en donc il y en a un là juste à droite
ok on l'a vu maintenant faudrait
peut-être trouver les auteurs moment
donné est-ce qu'il y en a par là bas
tout droit ntumi faut gagner pour un
moment donné nous devons sortir le
pastis ce bois-là galets devant ce jeu
de merde afin de ne pas voir de son maxi
je te promets mec
[ __ ] juste leur messie mais [ __ ]
vous l'avez pas vu mais [ __ ] vous êtes
aveugle
[ __ ] ils étaient là c'est quoi les
créatures d'avant alors mais qui a les
deux sur sa vie de chien
formé à l'as d'une blague au niveau
aujourd'hui 0 pour mac nec
alors là nous sommes absolument ma merde
c'est bien un moteur a disparu comme si
deux religieux tant attendu il ya eu des
sales pas de ram est qu une fille mal
baisées mais je n'ai entendu je n'ai pas
vu mais c'est là bas ce sera donc la
paiera plus à droite we love johnny ça
serait cool qu'on y arrive un jour je
comprends rien à la map il a été mis à
l'arrêt ou la fille popopo non 1,3 entre
ton 1 2 3 ta gueule ta gueule mais ce
que je veux on peut au même hôpital est
même retournée
on va chanter tes pas de moment de
centrer
un enfant
si je marque je suis moi
3 démarre ce jour il fait un peu par il
fait carrément peur j'en ai marre j'ai
envie de manger une tartine de nutella
bas
ça tu sors tu ça tue ça je ne suis pas
là je suis absent pour le moment vous
ayez laissé un message
après le flash s'honore pas ce qui
m'énerve c'est qu'en fait quand il voit
après il appelle sa fille
mais je trouverai jamais les si ce n'est
qu on tourne en rond depuis 20 minutes
comme n'a rien compris au mec tu
comprends pas peut-être cache pas elle
avait peut-être vu un truc mais là ça me
saoule mais ça repousse pour une
dernière les commandes à m
c'est toi tu étais un problème global
qui revient ce mois ce qui me rend ouf
c'est que la matte a cherché les dix
pages dans la forêt d'empreintes
elle les a trouvés stand la gang bang
elle s'est réveillée à l'aube et au lieu
de grimper un arbitre ferme aux étoiles
de voir où est la ville
elle va dans une mine pour activer des
générateurs pour que la mini la remontée
à la surface
je te dis alors que la mine était même
pas à la base en profondeur dans les
mots mais faut arrêter de déconner quoi
nos mères yammer ngomé faut y aller a
sense et que ce ne soit pas de la
frayeur gratuitement par l'ex par la
propriété il ya 100 circonflexe et de
l'action et du mélange l accent grave je
pense que tu vas mourir dans marguerite
isabelle label oui tu toi torride
isabelle margarita au tour en maths
containers tu sors tu habites à leur la
maxime de l'udc à zéro succès je propose
qu'on est un petit attends attends
attends quand on regarde là bas tu l'as
vu tu l'as vu partir non si moi j'ai vu
cette [ __ ] pendant que senna y rester
marguerite
wolfsburg vient vers toi mec me omez je
fais une frontale je fais une pour dater
ce qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce qui a
entamé la peau y tout pamela programme
homes à écouter à la prochaine j'espère
que cet épisode vous a bien fait chier
parce qu'ils étaient vraiment nul
bon c'est mickaël web mais bon voilà un
just rien de dingue
voilà bien de tout le monde pis pis